hi Matt here are you looking for another
great podcast our friends at Harvard
Business Review have a podcast you might
like hbr ideacast every Tuesday they
bring you the world's best business and
Leadership experts to help you manage up
manage a business and manage yourself
I'm a big fan of their recent episode
where a marketing professor and a
Matchmaker talk personal branding listen
to hbr ideacast for free wherever you
get your podcasts it's all you need to
lead
[Music]
trust is foundational to relationships
and communication
I can't have trust without rules
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
today I'm super excited to speak with my
friend and colleague anat anmadi who is
a professor of finance and economics at
Stanford GSB and the director of the
corporations and Society initiative
along with Martin Helwig anat co-wrote
the award-winning and highly acclaimed
book The Banker's new clothes what's
wrong with Banking and what to do about
it she teaches a number of courses
including power and finance and is the
internet broken which led to a cameo to
the TV show Silicon Valley welcome or
not I look forward to continuing our
coffee chats here on the podcast thank
you it's really great to be here let's
Jump Right In I have watched and
listened to you teach and present in a
variety of venues from classrooms to
Congress you have a superpower you are
really good at taking detailed complex
and sometimes convoluted Concepts and
making them understandable to the
average person
how do you do this
I realized that I actually had to do
that or I would just go back to my
cocoon in Academia basically I got
myself
into a political discussion about
banking regulation just by looking at
what's going on watching the news and
listening to what people say and then
saying wait a minute I'm a corporate
finance Professor what are they saying
what are they doing after the financial
crisis of 2007 to 2009 and so it really
was like oh I must have lived in some
bubble but as I came out of my bubble I
started interacting first with people I
know better which is the academics and
then going to the policy makers and so
that was the the beginning of this
journey and then it was clear after a
few years of this trying to talk to
these people is just not going to get
what I want
so that I had to then find ways to
communicate more broadly because that
was the only way to make progress if you
leave
this problem of banking to the people
involved and that includes both the
people in banking themselves and the
people in charge of supposedly keeping
us protecting us from any problems in
banking
you won't make progress and that's why I
had to find ways to communicate more
broadly so it sounds like you were
motivated by your mission
what are some of the things you learned
as you moved to the broader audience
that you now communicate with that have
helped you communicate better what I
learned was that I actually really had
to start where they are because
the issues are a little bit complicated
but not that complicated so it's not
rocket science as they say so it
deposits everybody understands what it
is and then you kind of go from that or
everybody takes a mortgage so everybody
can understand about mortgages so if you
start from that and then you take them
into you know what's a corporation
what's a balance sheet what's a bank
what's a bank run you know all of those
Concepts that they may have seen in the
movie someplace or they heard something
in the news and then you kind of try to
connect from where you started to the
current events and it's possible to do
it's not that hard it does take more
than a sentence or two sometimes but
it's doable completely because it's
really not that hard and then once you
give the analogies to things things
related to safety you know do we have a
building code do we have a speed limit
do we have this rule of that rule then
even in the broader context of you know
oh we hate radio relation or capitalism
socialism all these things we might get
to later you can make progress
so first you have to meet people where
they're at and then scaffold based on
Concepts and understandings that they
have and leveraging analogies I think is
is really powerful
now you often have had to argue for
unpopular positions held by very
powerful and entrenched people what have
you found Works to move people towards
your perspective or point of view well
it's the communication that we just
talked about in other words making them
really understand what you're saying
because people easily get confused by
these things there's obviously a lot of
communication on the other side so there
are armies of communication
professionals who are you know
propaganda marketing whatever you want
to call it is rampant so you're trying
to maybe unpack some of what they hear
and so that's the real challenge
especially if you're challenging people
with a lot of resources to get the views
that they have into people's heads what
happened to the power of Truth and of
course I come from education so I care
about truth but when you get to the
political domain and people say stuff
you know where do you start to
communicate with people starting with
something that you can maybe agree on
and going from there so when faced with
being the David to the Goliath in these
arguments it sounds like finding a place
to agree is a starting point and really
having your understanding of what you
want to get across is critical I think
one of the advantages you have and why
you have been successful to some extent
is because you come to this as an
educator and understanding that there's
some foundational principles so you do
need to be an expert and have actual
expertise so that you know what you're
talking about and then you need to try
to get that through now the challenge if
you're saying things that powerful
people don't like is that some of them
won't engage at all so you're just
emails talking into the wind and so you
the issue is actually finding people to
engage with and that became sort of a
little bit more difficult as memories of
that crisis receded and it's becoming a
little bit easier right now because all
of a sudden banking is in the news again
well I hope you do lean in because you
do have a lot of value to bring to this
conversation and and persistence
sometimes can lead to good results I
hate it along the way that to be worn
out by the other side and to just say
you know forget it because that's what
they want you to do they want to wear
you out you know they have more
persistence and more money to maintain
their narratives as a sort of advocate
for the public with no none of my own
interests in it just trying to help I'm
I'm kind of I realize the limits of my
power I'm glad that you're getting the
microphone again
I know you stand for transparency and
Clarity in finance specifically but
communication more generally why is this
so important to you and what can each of
us do to support your goals of
transparency
so first we need to know stuff and I
think part of the strategy of people in
much of the world who cause harm and
sometimes you know for the kinds of
objectives that we teach in a business
school is to obscure the facts and so I
really value investigative reporters and
I try to view myself as well and tell my
academic friends that we really are here
to speak truth to power and to try to
find that truth now that involves
finding facts but you have a lot of
powerful people using their money to
hide what happened I mean look at Harvey
Weinstein read you know catch and kill
he intimidated the media and he got his
misconduct hidden in these recent events
that we had with Silicon Valley bank and
now First Republic I'm curious uh what
are your thoughts on the role
communication plate or the lack of
communication and how is social media
played out in all of this communication
in banking is a lot about narratives so
we had a financial crisis and what what
happened so you know I often start by
saying well Jamie dimon famous guy
especially today said to his daughter
that a crisis is just stuff that happens
then you have other narratives that say
oh it was just a liquidity around like
in the movie It's a Wonderful World and
look at it this social media version of
it instead of people you know clamoring
to to get in the door of the bank we
have all these social media messages and
all these Mobile Banking and look at the
speed of it and all of that so it's the
modern version of you know Mary Poppins
rumor you know gets everybody to run to
the bank and want their money out and
certain people like that story because
if that's the story of what happened
then oh we should just ensure all
depositors which is just keep everybody
home so they don't run but
the problem is not this and this is an
effort to divert the discussion from
what the problem really is the problem
really is reckless management and bad
rules and bad enforcement of rules
so it's the governance that failed
and but that's not the story we're here
that's not the story if you hear only
about it Iran and how they needed to
meet payroll and they needed to
insurance for that reason and people who
left billions there without looking at
at whether they were safe or not then
this solution is always to just allow in
certain corporations in this economy to
do whatever they want with our money
how do you begin to change the narrative
how do you get that narrative out what
what what's the story you're telling and
who are you telling it to I want to tell
it to the public I want to tell the
public let's go to the actual problem
the people who wanted to pull their
money out of svb didn't just get up in
the morning and decide to do this
the reason for it was the money was not
safe
they had reason to do this it wasn't
just because they were afraid other
people were doing it which is sort of
the classic you know Panic qurans that
can take down a good bank no this was
not a good bank this was an insolvent
bank they showed their weakness because
they tried to sell some of their assets
which were just government bonds and it
wasn't like an illiquid Market it was
just a market in which their Bonds were
worth less than what they paid for them
and then they tried to raise more Equity
because that would help them pay their
debts and cover their deposits and they
couldn't if you're not able to raise
Equity that's a very huge flag they have
these stupid stress tests they run
that's a market test that you know any
corporation that wants to not be in
bankruptcy should pass now they might
not like the price they get for their
Equity if they lost a lot but it's maybe
the right price and so I now by now
studied extensively in my corporate
finance Theory had the Dynamics of
indebtedness for corporations it's just
very addictive and in banking the way we
have the system is feeding and enabling
the addiction to living on only debt it
seems to me that what I'm hearing you
say is the way you change the narrative
is you go back to the roots or the cause
and you make it very clear to people so
that they can understand what's really
going on it sounds also like part of
what's helping you be successful is that
you're making it very personal for
people to understand that it's about
safety it's about security it's about
honesty the scary thing right now is
we're getting the biggest banks to be
bigger and they are inscrutable we were
told
after the financial crisis if there
won't be any more bailouts the public
was very angry with the bailouts crypto
other phenomenons all the public anger
that got diverted by all kinds of people
through means of communications diverted
away from where the problems actually
are
and so during covid there was a lot of
obfuscation again because all people
were saying
look at the system and how it's doing
well you can do well if there's money
thrown all over the place and you take
little bits of it and because you sit in
the middle of it so it doesn't mean
anything about the regulation and so in
our new edition of the book we unpack
all of that and go a lot deeper into the
devilish details in ways people can
understand in ways of talking about why
no Executives went to jail all the
things that animate people about the
crisis which are less deregulation and
all the post-crisis movies especially if
you talk about communication
not necessarily all the books but the
movies were going only to that anger
about you know greed and recklessness
and and getting away with it which is
legitimate anger I look forward to the
new edition of your book it sounds like
it'll be quite the decoder ring to help
us understand in your work with the
corporations and Society initiative and
the teaching of your power and finance
course you illuminate several important
Concepts and constructs you think
everyone should know can you share one
or two of these and I'll give you extra
credit if you highlight the role of
communication in at least one of them
okay so the main theme
of my teaching is always governance and
it's kind of a framework which just
basically talks about power information
and incentives who's making decisions
what is it that they know what are their
constraints what motivates them to do it
and then how is it working out so that's
a governance framework that just helps
you think through every situation just
about
and then in order to have good
governance you need sort of trust and
accountability so let's just take the
trust because we already discussed
accountability yes what makes something
trustworthy you have to be genuine you
have to maybe look people in the eye you
are completely impartial to the
situation and then you're able to
actually say something that the listener
gets then that's how you you become
worthy of their trust now for
institutions how does an institution how
does a government the courts the Supreme
Court whatever be trustworthy so they're
all these tests of you know the trust
corporations corporate leaders
politicians all of that absolutely
governance is important and I love how
you use it as a way of setting a
Frameworks and ways of of thinking about
how we in a society interact and trust
is absolutely essential and the point
you made about not having a vested
interest can help establish that but let
me say if you have an interest it
doesn't mean that it's bad I can trust a
company the reason so sometimes you can
have a mission statement or a promise
but talk is cheap so how do I commit to
you so one of the other words is
commitment commitment and accountability
to have three words trust commitment and
accountability so where's the commitment
part coming I can commit to you that I
won't harm you because something bad
will happen to me if I harm you
that's why we need rules so how do I
promise you that you can trust me but
you have to have a mechanism to commit
to not harm the other person and then
you can be trustworthy so I bring in
rules as a way to create trust so if you
own the rules that's the ultimate power
and that's the problem in banking among
other things I love how you brought
communication as well as accountability
trust and rules all together so clearly
well you know that we end every one of
these podcasts with the same three
questions and and I would love to hear
your answers as we go through these so
for the first question or not if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you have ever received in a five
to seven word presentation slide title
what would it be
I'd say know your audience and meet them
where they are you've probably heard
this before but it is really the best
one uh we we hear know your audience a
lot the the added meet them where
they're at is really important and you
certainly have embodied that in the work
that you have done and so it's one thing
to say it it's another thing to sit down
with somebody who you can see very
regularly do it question number two who
is a communicator that you admire and
why there are a lot of good
communicators around but the admire part
was a little harder for me because there
are there are not as many so I found
kind of a it's almost too obvious an
example but it still is a good one and
that is Martin Luther King he is
certainly admirable is a communicator I
mean there's no question about that and
the more you look the more you realize
just how effective he was how persistent
he was and how passionate he was and how
he was able to mobilize his audiences
whether in writing or in speaking and so
I admire him for the communication but
especially for the cause he wanted
Justice and he deployed so many of the
techniques that we've talked about
previously in terms of knowing the
audience using analogies connecting and
Scaffolding very very wise choice for
sure question number three what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe two of
the threes we said in the beginning
understanding very well what you're
saying including your own shortcuts and
implicit assumptions because you would
be better when you truly understand what
you're saying second is again meeting
audiences but they are and third is
issue I think it's important to stick to
the issues and really avoid ad hominem
and people do God homonym and try to
discredit a person so knowing your
content and the biases you bring to it
really understanding your audience and
meeting them where they're at and
focusing on your message and your
purpose without getting distracted those
are absolutely three essential
ingredients I would argue well not I
knew this was going to be fun and I knew
we were going to learn a lot and I wish
you were just more passionate about what
you do it is it is a true experience and
a lot of fun to to always chat with you
thank you for the Insight you gave thank
you for the work you do and thank you
for sharing with us some really key
communication takeaways thank you very
much for having me
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB
foreign